Let's do one more.
We have two exercises for pmf and CDF because these
are quite important.
pmf and CDF exercise 2
and here's the question.
and you can just
I don't have five but
it can do the first two.
So we will leave the the next three four
you can do it on your own. I will
share the link to this document this.
To this, you know web page and you can
what kind of work on this on your own?
But it says this a mail order computer business has six telephone
lines a company has six telephone lines.
Let X denote the number of lines in use at
a specified time.
Okay. So for example in one experiment.
two telephone are
active
in another experiment six are
And suppose the pmf like the problem
again. Remember pmf probability distribution same thing suppose. They're
probably the distribution of the random variable X
is given in this table.
So when the value is at 0
like what is the probability that?
Zero lines will be used 10%
And the highest is 25% We have three lines.
that are
you know.
in use
so the exercise is for question one and two don't worry about
three four and five.
I will leave the answer to the previous question here for
your so you can compare.
And try to solve it.
So five minutes on this and we'll solve together. By the
way, if you work if you're looking at the exercise and
you're not able to you don't know where to
start.
Or if you if you're not certain about specific thing.
Put your question in the chat, even if this is your first time.
Put your questions in the chat.
in fact if you have any question about this
Topic altogether like statistics probability DNR
put your quest in the chat.